the corona virus pandemic that's
endangering our physical health is also
affecting our mental health a new CBS
News poll finds four in ten Americans
report feeling stressed in the past week
the CDC has a web page devoted to
managing anxiety and stress during the
outbreak and one recommendation involves
meditation in 2018 the agency reported
that the practice of meditation tripled
in the u.s. from 2012 to 2017 that is in
part due to the popularity of websites
and apps that are bringing the age-old
practice into the Information Age this
is what the company called calls the
world's most relaxing TV ad
it was released nationally in 2015
if all that serenity in the typically
noisy world of television commercials
catches your attention that's exactly
the point
calm is a technology company for
meditation sounds a little bit strange
and Michael Acton Smith understands why
indeed you know a great way to learn
meditation would be to have a teacher
and to sit there together and practice
and that's not our way of the world now
it seems like all of us almost four
billion people carry a phone with them
wherever they go
and so phones get a lot of criticism you
know they they are stressing us out in
many different ways but we believe they
are tools and we can use them in
incredibly mindful ways and help and
enhance their lives Acton Smith started
the company seven years ago with Alex -
so you meditated as a teenager yeah -
had already been practicing meditation
for years when he met his co-founder at
a London dinner party the pair hit it
off did you know at the time that you'd
end up in business together they were
sharing a house when they bought the
domain name calm calm we knew that
meditation itself you know has been long
misunderstood and if we could help bring
it to a new audience then it could
potentially be really widespread and
help millions of people which is now
what's happened but back then it was
still kind of unknown but meditation
dates back 5,000 years originating in
India around 1500 BCE though it began as
a spiritual practice today it's commonly
associated with helping lower stress and
negative emotions while gaining focus
and creativity people feel we're a bit
crazy there was a lot of cynicism that
was a lot of eye rolling now based in
San Francisco calms growth has been eye
popping when I open the app it's an
instant sense of relaxation comb says it
now has two million paid subscribers and
80 million downloads
last year the privately held company was
valued at 1 billion dollars making it in
Silicon Valley lingo a unicorn but we
just love to
idea of maybe one day creating the Nike
of the mind you know physical fitness
has been around for 50 years we think
we're right at the start of the mental
fitness revolution and we've always
thought of great athletes as the
strongest they now have something in
common with Nike three-time NBA champion
LeBron James as their pitchman strong
body not a sound mind the king is also
producing original content the mine is
like a muscle the more you train it the
stronger it becomes
and while the Great's mastered the body
the greatest mastered the mind we first
reported on calm back in October for a
story featuring their sleep stories
platform as you settle in under the
covers they added the bedtime stories
narrated by celebrities like Matthew
McConaughey about three years ago
palms content is normally available by
subscription only but for those feeling
anxious during the corona virus outbreak
they've added free material to their
blog congratulations on finding some
headspace and taking the time to look
after your mind
so has rival company headspace it's made
its entire platform free for us
healthcare professionals and is offering
select free content research shows is
easier to create a new habit workers and
educators last week headspace even
released a video showing how to wash
your hands mindfully the sensation of
the running water covering the skin in
the past meditations may be seen more as
a lifestyle kind of choice headspace
co-founder Andy Padukone
talked about the growing acceptance of
meditation in a 2018 appearance on CBS
this morning
I think that's a real kind of shift in
the past it was maybe seen as something
that women would do and and with it
being on the phone man I think often
feel like actually there's something
private they can do they don't need to
necessarily discuss with anybody or tell
anyone some days meditation will feel
easy the growing popularity has made
online meditation a crowded field
there are now more than ten apps
dedicated to helping you gain some inner
peace nothing feels more urgent than
sitting still to calms Michael Acton
Smith that's been the core mission all
along and I think it's exciting as well
because there's not many businesses
where you can do something genuinely
good for the world
tom is helping so many different people
to sleep to reduce stress we all need
that right now again a lot of these have
a lot of free platforms excuse me right
now I know it's difficult but just give
it a shot because you'd be amazed when
you breathe when you take that breath in
and concentrate and focus on it it
really does make a difference
and the sensation of the running water
companies I don't feel that way I like
that I like what your daughter is doing
with the happy birthday but that's okay
you are absolutely right the breathing
is the key right in that's right there
we go